[Music]
if that's so sweet news play I likes
what did you say
that's all flat submitted by orange or
grape Fanta great brunch yeah or is it
true yeah
the Fanta girls are hot do you wonder
Fanta the new ones are like YouTube yeah
you know I never seen them you know
neither you know Lauren is one of them
she's a fun to girl yeah who's about to
go Lord Lu Lauren DIY who's that Oh
Allison [ __ ] from Alex she liked my
Japanese little sister yeah I thought it
was Lauren Nishizawa CooCoo CooCoo sake
anyway an 84 year old devoted husband
has learned to do his wife's makeup
before she goes completely blind oh
that's so cute like that I'll say to her
head some of the best makeup artists
I've ever had have been dudes yeah cuz
guys are better artists I know actually
if you guys didn't know in the industry
it was originally all men that were
makeup artists yeah but you know it
doesn't count cause they're gay guys
doesn't count
no no no because it's like it's like you
can't blame straight guys for it what No
like I had a really good straight male
makeup artist on the show I did and he
was talking about his wife the whole
time yeah when I was getting my makeup
did I found out through an older guy cuz
he even doing it for like years he was
like prob like in his 50s or something
or 60s or some [ __ ] and he was telling
me about the history of like makeup
artists huh originally only men the
theater was only men like entertainment
was only men although female parts were
played by a guys yeah well he's not that
[ __ ] old he's got a little Japan
like talking about kabuki [ __ ] is going
on like I just said he's like fifty or
sixty years old it makes sense why it's
mainly males on it yeah why why does it
make sense because the women weren't
allowed to work yeah I got stay home and
raise children and [ __ ] the good old
days but there were all the ladies
working yeah but that's one when they
let them work yeah that's the only
dammit he's only 50 or 60 years of same
on name
why are you doing math right now hey
that's after 40 he was born after World
War 2 or maybe a baby boomer yeah see
he's math did stop correcting me this
one says 83 and the title said 84 84
year-old husband why are you reading I
don't know he probably had a birthday as
they were writing it now I see why he's
going blind so she is slowly losing her
son you can't do that cat eye anymore
with the liner from Ireland cuz I'll be
like I'll be like all good news baby
you know what you don't have to do
makeup anymore you know what I honestly
thought you guys would have to worry
about your face I totally heard the guys
in this room thing Yeah right he's not
sweet he's - look at her I thought these
tummy guys were gonna be like dummy huh
scummy
what's a stomach stomach yes dummy huh I
thought you guys were gonna be like damn
too bad you can't see this like six-pack
anymore they just got for you girl what
he's 84 this is why you guys you've
never seen puff eighty four-year-old
never I'm not trying to make jokes
that's like literally right
David huh [ __ ] joke yeah funny right
now though nothing funny about that
she's going blind you [ __ ] sick
freaks yeah I thought it was very funny
this one's funnier looks like the
[ __ ] hot dog water that's what it
looks like right here Damon put your
Cryptkeeper [ __ ] fingers out of my
face
[ __ ] you alright I don't water yeah
that's why you should have it it looks
like this yeah that was his joke that
was the wait you're right David that was
way funnier it actually was in your
[ __ ] face you [ __ ] bags and the
actual joke was the fact that it wasn't
funny and nobody gets that hot dog water
reference unless they already saw the
others you actually not a hot dog water
reference anymore is how bark passes
water to people yes exactly we set it up
for the joke
thank you I think this guy's very sweet
and I like that he learned how to do
math would you do that to geo not faded
her head don't even get me started with
that [ __ ] I want to know he was he
looked at me like this was fading my
hair for the first time when I had my
first oh he's coming to your school my
side chief Oh cut into your ski ass dude
and I was like oh my god guys have to go
through this every two weeks but my [ __ ]
was bumpy it wasn't red and I was like
oh my god you guys this sucks I'm sure I
do it clean but whatever and then it
went to an actual barber shop and it was
the most pleasant experience yeah I mean
even the way he washes his face is
[ __ ] up yo he actually has perfect
vision originally he ruined it through
his head the first time I ever saw this
we'll wash his face when we live a
keishon together I was like what are you
doing
[Laughter]
do you know that they make noise and now
I do is like this suction thing and I'm
like what is that noise and I'm like
stop it's [ __ ] unreal jack about like
[Laughter]
does he do a good job or as he equally
is blind like let me do it for you
this [ __ ] Parkinson's and everything
like a scribble scribble imagine it's
all like [ __ ] bright PD I was like
Mass I'll be so happy if I could do that
[ __ ] cuz every day it'll be like a clown
or like a happy carnival elephant or
something maybe something different and
dance did he do her makeup right there
cuz I'm [ __ ] adorable yes she is you
don't see the eye line no they've been
going to the Benefit beautycounter and
like this door yeah there's a little
local lead to them and so they've been
learning from amiko parties been
learning from me covered
oh that's awesome like they'll go they
go often like almost every day they say
cuz they think I should do oh they're
like raisins they got [ __ ] to do
no but so she still hasn't lost her
sight completely so he said that he
wanted to be really good at putting on
her makeup at the time she completely
lost her sight that's so sad a 30 minute
cover no it was almost like an hour
conversation with my mom about [ __ ]
rice right no I didn't hurt like yeah
and her husband and he was like I'm a
rice expert and in like somehow yeah it
was about rice do you finger your eyes
to check the anyone when did three
people's feel about like you know
[Laughter]
you gonna wash your rice yeah we got to
wash it sometimes soaked in so when he
proposed to me he said because my back
is [ __ ] up that's like scoliosis have
to get massages and carries all like
it's all knots in there
no he said he would take masseuse
classes to learn how to give massage I
can't believe he trapped me that way I
know he does not take good one masseuse
class and then he's like I watched
videos on how to do it those like okay
show me what video did you watch some
people just don't have that massage gene
in them dude cuz oh yes big feel good
yeah cuz he's gotten better over the
years with my guidance you know I think
he's gotten better but he still thinks
that like once he felt like if I'm like
oh that feels good he's like harder and
faster then I'm like no yeah it's so
good right there just trying to [ __ ]
your back sex what women need that
rhythm to come you know and it's like
with the massaging you just you see see
that same rhythm in a cow massage is
somebody with oils is way easier like if
you're ever gonna give somebody a long
massage don't just do it straight there
and just get it massage you can use a
forearm maybe do everything you don't
have to press this hard either that's
great David teach these men how to
massage that massage their women
yeah please not ferrell comes like this
we're like shoulders that means jess is
facing bounty
[Laughter]
via Fresh Prince right now that's so
cute her makeup turn a same hi or did he
shrink on a Polish wrong I'm a shrink
you know the last time I saw my mom wear
makeup was when she was at a funeral and
that's it like she doesn't wear makeup
anymore
maybe she's shrunk and she's like geo
that's true like now she shrunk I'm
gonna be part of jail right there yeah
she ain't got no teeth either look at
that [ __ ] what everyone look kind of
like Asian when they're old and Asian's
don't look Asian anymore what do they
look like white they legit look like sea
turtles he's had this thought that's
true my grandpa I'll bring a picture of
the next time he looked exactly like a
sea turtle walking so you cried know why
every time yeah every time yeah my
grandpa was interesting though he was a
he was a cool it's like a turtle right
now he does he looks like a [ __ ]
really like a desert tortoise you know
come and plays and Tigers play play this
[ __ ] roof lakes are all over the
place hook is a foot fling he just saw
mud get dry it's [ __ ] just dandruff
off his foot there's foot drop do you
need to give your dad some lotion man
works off what if cyclic quitting it can
you tell the boys who need a
moisturizers feet dude he does because
the [ __ ] is going on dude hold the
pineapple bun top feet dude we got
[ __ ] right
[Music]